Paramount you've just announced that
Star Trek Academy has been green lit and
this really just go against a lot of the
rumors we've been hearing for a few
months so what happened
welcome to Sidetrack here Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so as I've told you in previous videos
there have been lots and lots of
anti-kirtsmen Whispers and the thing
that I was hearing was that we wouldn't
get a Star Trek announcement for
probably six months that would have been
around Star Trek day sort of September
but we've had a couple of quite big
announcements this week the biggest
though being that Starfleet Academy has
been green lit we are going to get Star
Trek 90210 whether we want it or not and
this is going to be by the looks a
follow-on from Star Trek Discovery a
show that also a lot of people don't
really want
so what is actually going on what a
Paramount planning and how has this
happened
well I'm hearing again a couple of
rumors and we've got to put all of this
very firmly in the rumor category we'll
talk about it because I've been told it
but even my sources is not really sure
and this is surprised now I obviously
speak to lots and lots of different
people One Source in particular it has
an agenda against Alex kurtzman I've
known that for a long time it's very
much a woke sort of ideology sort of
thing is coming from I believe and even
though they come up with some very
interesting information it does come
from a perspective of wanting Alex
kurtzman out of Star Trek now that
Source has been proved wrong basically
by everything that's been happened in
the last week or so but other sources
other more reliable sources that
actually do work in and around areas
that I can trust have agreed in lots of
respects that Parliament have had big
problems and big concerns with secret
hideout and and they have been hesitant
to Greenlight some of these projects now
as I told you last week I was told that
secret hideout and Paramount were still
having conversations and that even
though section 31 and Stafford Academy
were possible still they were unlikely
now the reason why I was talking about
was because basically section 31 was
very much reliant on Michelle young and
that it seemed very unlikely that that
was going to happen and that other
pictures including staffy Academy were
really reliant on that now this stuff
Academy idea has been being bounced
around for
30 years on and off and has been talked
about by kurtzman since
2017 so like five years really very
early on at the start of Star Trek it's
been a popular idea within certain
sections for a very long time now if you
actually talk to the podcast guys they
will say and they did a video months ago
saying actually the Starfleet Academy
was 100 gonna happen as soon as
Discovery ended we'd get started for the
Academy now they've got brilliant
sources in and around Star Trek but
they've also got enough common sense to
know when certain people say things they
probably happen but there are a lot of
voices out there as I say with an agenda
against kurtzman now these people are
not necessarily lying when they share
this information but they get bits of
information from Paramount or other
areas and they put that perspective on
it and that's something that I know for
me listening to rumors that come in and
around I have to be careful of but in
this case it does seem almost certainly
because again another source that I do
trust has said that actually yes it is
true the Palmer we're having concerns it
is true that Picard Series 3 and the
success of that has helped to leave some
of those concerns also the success of
strange new worlds
it's also true that
the source that I speak to that does
work for quite a large agency in
Hollywood says that a lot of people in
and around the offices yesterday were
very surprised when this dropped they
were not expecting it because they were
expecting something around September
so what changed the rumor always was
that we would not get Starfleet Academy
unless we got section 31 and we wouldn't
get section 31 Unless kurtzman somehow
managed to get Michelle yo on board
so the question they're asking is is
Michelle you're on board have they at
the very least got Michelle yeoh to do
some sort of limited series and that the
success of getting oscar-winning
Michelle Yeo to do a Star Trek series
however brief has given them enough
leverage to get Paramount to agree to
Starfleet Academy now I actually think
we're going to know whether this idea
and I'm going to say this idea this is
based on this person's opinion is a
person that's worked in this injury for
a very long time does hear things
um but again his opinion we're going to
know about this quite soon because he
says he's looking at April the 5th one
of the things he also said was why have
they announced this today why have they
have announced this when actually we've
still got three four episodes of Star
Trek Picard left we've still got this
big event on April the 5th and Frontier
day we've still then actually got the
Federation day
why is it announced it today why not
announce it just before the Sarah may be
serious finale of Picard and create a
really big buzz
well it says maybe it's because they're
holding off on the big announcement
that's the Michelle yeoh project
whatever that's going to look like
now that makes sense to me so let's just
think about how this has worked
Alex kurtzman we've kept saying and kept
pitching this section 31 idea with
Michelle yo Paramount Executives or at
least parts of Paramount didn't believe
him and thought that he was making big
promises but didn't actually expect him
to be able to fulfill them and that when
he then did
it kind of took the legs from under them
took the wind out of their sails and all
of a sudden the voices they'll support
Alex kurtzman got the upper hand and he
got what he was asking for
now I can imagine that actually the lots
of the other rumors about the smaller
budget I keep being told that almost
everything paramedic when you're doing
is going to be based on a 20 less budget
than what we looked at previously so the
budget for Discovery off top of my head
was about 8 million we could look at
more like maybe six for whatever they do
moving forwards that is just the reality
of stream Services have spent too much
money in the last 10 years and they need
to spend less
but they can still produce something
pretty amazing for that money they just
have to make sure that every dollar ends
up on the screen but why has kurtzman
gone for this Star Trek 90210 Starfleet
Academy idea
well again the rumor is that Discovery
has quite a young demographic there's a
young audience that found this show and
Paramount don't want to lose that young
audience
but is the wider Star Trek audience
excited by this well I can tell you my
personal opinion I don't like this idea
I don't like Discovery I have nothing
against curse when I don't have an
agenda in this respect at all I just
never liked the show I didn't like the
Klingons from the start it kind of put
me off I found the characters a little
boring I even though I thought it was
beautifully made and actually some of
the stories were fascinating
I just didn't care about the characters
so I stopped watching it I barely
watched any of season three and I don't
think I watched any of season four I
love strange new worlds I love Star Trek
Picard season three but this idea of
Staffing Academy
it turns me off now it looks like from
the announcement that this is going to
be based following
um Star Trek Discovery because there's a
few mentions about that Starfleet
Academy hadn't existed for 100 years Etc
so that seems to put us firmly in the
post burn
post-discovery era it also mentions that
there are applications being requested
for anybody that wants to join Starfleet
Academy 16 and above so we're going to
see a young cast maybe with some of the
cast from Discovery being pulled through
as maybe teachers
but on the whole this is going to be
based around a young cast
a lot of people keep saying I don't
really want to see a teenage angst TV
show based around Star Trek but Buffy
the Vampire Slayer was a teenage tank
show and I personally loved it so there
is a possibility that this could still
be a good show at the end of the day I
always think about things like
there's the Lucifer TV show break that
down
Satan comes to Earth and fights crime
it's the stupidest storyline you could
possibly think of
but I loved it it was great it worked
now I say Star Trek 90210 Starfleet
Academy following a bunch of kids that's
so stupid and I don't want to watch it
but if done right it could be brilliant
Alex kurtzman is actually co-show
running this with ogolanda
now again this is very much in the rumor
category but one person I spoke to that
possibly does have an agenda but his
opinion is still valid is that this has
happened because of the doubts about
Alex kurdzman that Alec Paramount have
said yes we'll go with this and if and
yes you can show run but we want to
bring somebody else in we want there to
be a team around this we do not want the
mistakes of early Discovery now we don't
know if this decision to bring in Landau
came from secret hideout as part of that
compromise that they went back to
Paramount and said well what if we do it
this way would you make you happier or
this is a directive from Paramount we
don't know but either way it seems that
the fact that the way they have put
together this production team is very
much in line with what we believe about
Paramount's opinion about kurtzmann's
creative control over the show but it
also may be that actually kurtzman just
needs help because he is the top top guy
in secret hideout and secret hideout are
producing a lot of TV right now now
there is also another rumor going around
and actually this Starfleet Academy is
always going to happen because Curtin
has a contract extension with Paramount
and that that contract extension says
that there has to be five TV shows well
there was a contract with Paramount and
it did sort of talk about Five Star Trek
shows but that was extended and when it
was extended the new extension doesn't
mention Star Trek secret hideout do
other projects for Paramount and it
doesn't specifically talk about Star
Trek now apparently that means that
Paramount we're not under any obligation
to actually announce this show
but there's been a little bit of a
perfect storm of success for kurtzman
and that might have just given him the
leverage he needed to get what he wanted
finally I just want to share this with
you though because as soon as I heard
this news last night before I put my
head on the pillow and went to sleep I
asked you guys is this a show that you
think is a good idea so I put a poll on
the channel
is the announcement of Alex kurtzman LED
Star Trek and a follow-on from Discovery
a massive backward step for Star Trek
and I put the answers yes huge mistake
no more track is awesome
77 of you guys believe that this is a
huge mistake and only 23 have said more
Star Trek is awesome don't care
that's out of 504 votes at the point of
filming now this is a Sci-Fi channel you
guys are sci-fi fans and nearly 80
percent of you do not want Star Trek
Academy
all I would ask that 80 is keep your
mind open it really does depend on how
this show is pulled off
let's not worry about early Discovery
let's not worry about
seasons one or two Picard
let's think about the great Star Trek
that we've had in the last couple of
years strange new worlds lower decks
Prodigy and Picard season three
these people have been able to do some
of the best Star Trek we've seen in a
very very long time I'm excited about
Fridays again when I get to see Picard
season 3 episode
maybe they can make us excited about
staff at the Academy as well
and if the big announcement is a section
31 Michelle yo series and even if that
is maybe just a few episodes you know
like a very limited series
that was really something I would be
genuinely excited to see so let's see
what happens in the next few days but
when you think you can be assured it is
I will be here to talk about the rumors
and the announcements and we will
continue our conversation
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com
where I get most of my videos on there
first for all of the patrons
as always please stay safe I'm gonna go
watch Picard season three
I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]